[Music]
he's been called Russia's Bob Dylan
Boris grabinjikov and his band aquarium
have been rocking crowds like this one
in Toronto for five decades making his
American television debut please welcome
Boris grebenchikov
that's him with David Letterman in 1989
just months before the Berlin Wall came
down do the Russians know you're here uh
but grabinjikov's powerful voice has now
been silenced in his own country one day
after Russia invaded Ukraine
gravinchikov called the war Russia's
Madness and shame in an interview with
global news he doubled down the evil
sort of Zed Petras
crying kill the ukrainians
and this is madness rabinchikov is now
facing criminal charges in Russia and up
to 15 years in prison he has no plans to
return anytime soon but even outside
Russia the kremlin's political opponents
say they're not safe
[Music]
I'm in a constant state of fear says
Russian political activist Artur zaripov
a couple of years ago zaripov's
anti-kremlin protests landed him in
prison
arrested in dramatic fashion accused of
terrorism after 18 months zaripov was
released on house arrest and managed to
escape the country he's now living in
Poland but even there he's been detained
and eventually released four times
I found out that I was on interpol's
Wanted list he says European countries
know Putin is a liar I don't understand
why they're still cooperating with
Russia through Interpol Interpol is the
world's largest International police
organization with 195 member states but
Russia is single-handedly responsible
for a whopping 38 percent of all public
Interpol red notices and critics say the
Kremlin is abusing the system to hunt
down its political opponents following
the invasion of Ukraine Canada the U.S
and others called for Interpol to
suspend Russia in a statement the agency
says its Constitution calls on the
organization to maintain police
cooperate nation and ensure
communication channels remain open nor
is there any provision in the
constitution for the suspension or
exclusion of a member country Russia
should have been suspended from Interpol
long before the invasion of Ukraine
prominent Kremlin critic Bill Browder
says Russia has tried to add him to
interpol's Wanted list eight times he
was arrested in Spain in 2018 sparking a
global outcry and it was only because I
tweeted out when I was being arrested
that a whole International Firestorm was
created but for a lot of people that
wouldn't happen
[Music]
Russia's political opponents say every
time they cross a border they risk
arrest or worse but grabinjikov won't be
silenced that's the way I feel you know
I can't conceal that if you keep silent
it still corrosive from inside Jeff
sample Global News Toronto
[Music]